how's it going everybody it's war and
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and we
have some pretty big
spider-man no way home news as i
mentioned in my past videos now that the
filming for spider-man no way home is
done
and the editing process has begun we
could be getting some major leaks coming
and that is definitely true but today's
news actually comes from
the actors themselves we have news about
toby maguire and spider-man no way home
and of course
those crazy viral videos of andrew
garfield going around of him stating
that he's not going to be in the film
however
i'll break down why he is most likely
lying so if you were bummed out about
andrew garfield stating that he's not in
spider-man no way home which by the way
he didn't exactly state
that don't be bummed out because it
doesn't really mean anything at this
point in time and i'll break down what
that means
in this video but quick reminder i'm
still doing my stormbreaker giveaway all
you have to do to enter subscribe to me
and my other channel cosmic culture
details in the description down below so
before we dive into the
not one but two videos of andrew
garfield stating that he's not going to
be in no way home
let's talk about the recent tobey
maguire news
pizza time recently toby maguire was
spotted in l.a he was just simply
walking down the street
walking his dog now of course that alone
doesn't really mean anything but if you
combine it with a few things things
start to get a little bit more clear
the last time we saw toby maguire out in
public he was going to get fitted for a
costume now obviously the costume was
not revealed
but the speculation was that he was
getting fitted for another spider-man
costume
it had been a few years many years since
he put on his old spider-man costume
from the sam raimi universe
so he needed to get fitted for another
one and here's the thing
when we saw him going to that fitting he
looked very different he had a beard he
wasn't really
in that good of shape and here's the
real kicker he doesn't have any upcoming
movies toby maguire hasn't actually been
in a film since 2017 in which he just
did a
voice over for boss baby he was rumored
to be eyed for the movie babylon but
that movie is kind of at a standstill
right now and nothing official has been
announced and since nothing official has
been announced for that film and it's
kind of at a standstill it doesn't make
sense that he would go to a fitting for
the movie so the logical explanation
is he was going to a fitting for
spider-man no way home
in which he would have already filmed
now he's back in l.a and he looks a lot
better
he doesn't have a beard anymore and it
looks like he's in a lot better shape
now of course he doesn't do all of the
major stunts but he does do
some of the things that spider-man does
just like tom holland kind of does some
of his own stunts as well
now he's a little older so he does less
but since he hasn't really done much
since 2017 in which he just did a voice
over roll
simply coming back to do a little bit of
the spider-man moves would put him in
better shape which
now he looks like he is in and it's also
kind of funny how he wasn't really
spotted
in la between that time we saw him where
we believed he was getting the fitting
and now after the filming of spider-man
no way home
so essentially he really wasn't spotted
in public in l.a during the whole entire
filming of spider-man
no way home this is all pretty
coincidental that's a lot of things
coming together
pointing towards him being in spider-man
no way home there have been plenty of
reports stating that he is coming back
along with andrew garfield and heck
they could be wrong but at this point in
time so many different outlets have
reported that he is going to be in the
film and there has been so much
evidence towards this like his stunt
double being on the set of spider-man no
way home and that is confirmed
it would just be insane if he actually
really wasn't in the film
so of course it's not 100 confirmed and
it won't be until marvel studios
straight up comes out and says it or we
actually see them in the teaser trailer
it's still pretty high like 95 confirmed
and i would actually say the same for
andrew garfield despite what he's been
saying in recent interviews i'm sure a
lot of you know what i'm talking about
but if you don't don't worry i'll
explain
recently andrew garfield has been doing
some interviews for
another movie that he's in and of course
the people that were interviewing him
had to ask about his involvement in
spider-man no way home
and here's what he said to josh horowitz
from the happy sad confused podcast
because obviously i don't even want to
like ruin anything if there is something
to ruin
except there isn't anything to ruin bro
i have to just quickly just cut you off
there's nothing to ruin really like like
it's so crazy
like it's just gotten out of hand this
is all [ __ ] dude it's [ __ ]
hilarious to me because it's like
because i because i do have this twitter
account and i like i see
like how often like spider-man is
trending and it's like people
freaking out about a thing and i'm just
like
guys guys guys like
i i wish i could just like be able to
speak to everyone and say like
how did this take off because you you
are i recommend that you chill
like like listen i can't speak for
anything else apart from myself sure
like like they might be doing something
but there
[Music]
okay well that makes my life easier okay
no that's good that's unequivocal you
know what it feels like though it feels
like because this hasn't come up yet in
an interview but like
do you ever play the game werewolf no
or mafia yeah yeah yeah yeah uh-huh you
know that game
i think it's kind of similar where it's
like you're convincing everyone that
you're not
in the mafia right like i feel like i'm
in a game of [ __ ]
werewolf or mafia where i'm like i'm not
the werewolf i promise you i am not the
werewolf and everyone's like you're the
werewolf you're the [ __ ] werewolf
look at him he's like he's doing
so pretty hilarious if it were true i
don't really believe him
josh goes on to ask him straight up so
are you in this film you're not
in this film and he doesn't give a
direct answer
okay so for the record my friend on a
stack of whatever you have there you are
not
as of this taping in or have any
knowledge of being in the next
spider-man movie
i feel like like i feel i feel like i
like haven't i just said that i just
want to get really clear on what this is
this the unequivocal yes no answer
i did not get a call
maybe they shot you guerrilla style like
in main street mainstream
listen listen i would i would have
gotten a call by now that's what i'm
saying
okay um i don't wanna like i don't wanna
run anything out maybe they wanna call
me maybe they're gonna call me
like and say like hey so what it seems
like is that he definitely has some type
of scripted material that he uses
if he's asked by these media outlets and
television shows that he just says
because
let's be honest if he was in the movie
which i believe he is he can't say that
he's in it so he sticks to this
werewolf story and i haven't gotten a
call story that seems pretty rehearsed
as we see here he actually says this
again in another interview
in spider-man
what do you what do you think of those
rumors i feel i
feel like i'm in a game of werewolf and
i'm just saying i'm not the werewolf
i am not the werewolf i promise you guys
i'm not the werewolf
um so yeah i mean listen
what people are talking about is a
really cool idea
and and and again i haven't received a
phone call but
you know what do people expect him to
say he can't say yes
he can't just say yeah i am in the new
spider-man movie with tom holland and oh
toby maguire spider-man is going to come
back as well it's going to be super
awesome and the spider-verse is really
cool
he can't say that i wish he could but he
can't and this whole i didn't get a call
statement and the whole werewolf
statement kind of seems very rehearsed
maybe something kevin feige told them to
say
because in all of these interviews he
has never once said
no i am not in the movie which is also
kind of odd because many actors in the
past have simply said no
i'm not in the film in fact we have
clips of other actors like paul rudd
stating no
i'm not the ant-man that's a rumor or do
you remember only a few months ago where
a media outlet reported that tatiana
manslainey was going to be playing
jennifer walters aka she-hulk but then
she came out and actually denied that
she was going to be playing she-hulk
and commander ant-man was oh that's all
rumor man
all right nothing i know all right she's
from her emmy-winning role
on orphan black so marvel seemed like a
perfect fit for her
yeah well tatyana now says not so fast
in an interview with the sudbury star
yesterday what's up sudbury tatiana said
that actually isn't a real thing and
it's like a press release that's gotten
out of hand it's totally not
i've been connected to these things in
the past and press has gotten on to it
but it's not actually a thing
unfortunately only for it to be
confirmed at disney's investor day not
too long after that
so again andrew just can't come out and
say hey yeah
i'm in the film that's never going to
happen until they actually reveal that
but if we take a look at all of the
evidence like jamie foxx's electro
returning alfred molina's dog awk
returning
plus not to mention alfred molina
stating that they're going to pick up
where they left off in spider-man 2 from
that river scene combined with the fact
that both andrew garfield
and toby mcguire stunt doubles have been
seen on set
and in fact andrew garfield stunt double
has posted several videos of him on the
set
and he's also tagged in his post both
toby maguire's and tom holland stunt
doubles as well
plus a bunch of other little pieces of
evidence that all comes together that
points towards the fact that both
andrew and toby are going to be in
spider-man no way home
now if they're really not in the movie
i'm going to be completely shocked
because of all of this evidence pointing
towards the fact that they
are in the film so it's not officially
confirmed but i'm betting that they
really are
but let me know your thoughts about this
in the comments down below what do you
think about all of this evidence what do
you think about andrew garfield saying
in these interviews
do you think they're going to be in the
film or not let me know and don't forget
to subscribe so you can stay up to date
on all the latest spider-man no way home
news don't forget to like this video and
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you